comment au début des années 30 les
correspondants de presse étrangers
ont-ils relaté la montée en puissance et
la prise de pouvoir légal d'Adolf Hitler
et du nazisme en Allemagne nous venons
donc de le découvrir grâce à ce
documentaire signé par Jean Bulot et
pour continuer de s'interroger sur ce
qui restera malheureusement voilà 90 ans
comme un moment clé de l'histoire du 20e
siècle trois invités sont maintenant
présents à mes côtés sur ce plateau de
débat doc Daniel Schneiderman tout
d'abord bienvenue à vous vous êtes
journaliste auteur fondateur du site
arrêt sur image du nom bien sûr de
l'émission que vous avez animé pendant
12 ans sur France 5 on vous a entendu vu
témoigner dans ce dans ce film mais pour
cause puisqu'on vous doit entre autres
Berlin 1933 la presse internationale
face à Hitler un ouvrage publié aux
éditions du Seuil ouvrage qui serait
suivi d'un autre qui s'intitule la
guerre avant la
1936-1939 lui aussi publié au Seuil
annette diviorka est également avec nous
bienvenue à vous à net viglorca on est
toujours très heureux de vous recevoir
dans cette émission vous êtes
historienne spécialiste de la Shoah et
de l'histoire des Juifs au 20e siècle
votre dernier ouvrage s'intitule tombeau
autobiographie de ma famille ouvrage
personnel on l'a compris publié lui
aussi au seuil pour lequel d'ailleurs
vous avez obtenu le Prix féminin l'an
dernier et puis enfin Bruno fulini est
également avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
historien écrivain les folles les lois
folles pardon de la République c'est le
titre de votre dernier ouvrage il est
publié 8 chez Jean-Claude lattes je vous
propose de recontextualiser ce qui était
l'ambiance et le rapport de force
politique existant en Allemagne dans ces
fameuses années 30 dont il est question
dans le documentaire avec ce qui nous
remet en tête et en mémoire ce qui ont
été les résultats du parti nazi aux
élections législatives comment sont 1924
avec 31 députés au Reichstag à
l'occasion de d'élections législatives
ça représente 6,6 % des voix c'est un
parti qui est encore minoritaire mais là
on sort du procès qui a jugé Hitler pour
son fameux putsch organisé en Bavière et
ça a créé une notoriété auprès de la
population allemande ce procès c'est là
semble-t-il qu'il s'est fait connaître
par les Allemands à travers ce process
qui expliquerait en grande partie ce
score de 6,1 6% en 1924 evidemment le
fait marquant dans ce graphique c'est le
score obtenu en mai 1928 2,6% et surtout
celui obtenu en septembre
1930 18,3% nous sommes après après la
crise de 29 après ce fameux craque de la
crise de 29 le parti nazi devient alors
le deuxième parti politique en Allemagne
et puis nous arrivons à cette fameuse
année 1932 première législative en
juillet 32 37,4 % le parti nazi est bel
et bien le premier parti politique en
Allemagne il le restera en 1932 mais
cette fois en novembre même si son score
est un petit peu moins élevé qu'en
juillet 32 et puis enfin ce sont les
élections de mars 1933 dissolution
provoquée par les nazis où ils
obtiennent cette fois
43,9% des suffrages autrement dit 288
députés au Reichstag mais dans un
contexte tout à fait différent mars 33
puisqu'à ce moment là il est au pouvoir
et il exerce déjà le parti nazi exerce
déjà une terreur sur la vie politique
allemande les députés communistes ne
peuvent pas siéger les électeurs
opposants ne peuvent pas côté où sont
dissuadés d'aller voter dont on peut pas
on peut pas comparer les 43% de mars cet
événement majeur qui a été l'instant dit
du
Reichstag février une séquence à part
celle qui va du 30 janvier 33 jusqu'à
ses élections de mars alors je dois dire
si vous permettez quelque chose qu'on
rentre dans le débat comme on est là
pour parler de la presse
un autre graphique ce sera le dernier
c'est promis mais cette fois parce qu'il
est important il est il en était
fortement question dans le documentaire
cette fois c'est la présidence de mars
1932 parce que beaucoup de
correspondants étrangers ont compris
dans le documentaire sont venus couvrir
cette élection et regardez bien Adolf
Hitler contrindra Hindenburg un second
tour où il obtiendra tout de même à ce
second tour de présidentiel 13,4
millions des voix autrement dit c'était
déjà le double des législatives de 1930
on sent bien la pression et la montée en
puissance d'Adolf Hitler à ce moment-là
c'est le défaut intrinsèque de
présidentielle allemande dans le cadre
de la République de Weimar c'est qu'il
peut y avoir plus de deux candidats au
second tour et que donc le candidat
communiste talmane se maintient
absolument voir et donc il faut savoir
que si dans les institutions françaises
de la 5ème République il peut y avoir
que deux candidats au second tour c'est
une réminiscence qu'avait les
constituants de 58 de ce qui s'était
passé en Allemagne avec l'élection du
Président de la République au suffrage
universel et c'est vrai que parmi tous
ceux qui ont joué un rôle dans
l'ascension de Hitler au pouvoir il a
été question de papel on va en reparler
il y a aussi le rôle du KPD qui est un
parti communiste extrêmement dur pas du
tout prêt à s'allier ni avec les
socialistes bien sûr et encore moins
avec la droite et qui du coup va se
suicider littéralement va s'enfermer
dans une dans une logique telle que
finalement
est élu un peu par défaut avec un score
assez médiocre et Hitler va avoir une
légitimité importante par ailleurs ce
parti communiste allemand fait peur et
donc pour beaucoup d'Allemands les nazis
vont être un rempart bon alors si on
rend si on commence à rendre les
communistes responsables de l'arrivée du
d'Hitler au pouvoir je pense qu'on va
voir un débat assez animé sur ce plateau
je voudrais dire juste auparavant dire
quelque chose sur les journalistes
puisque effectivement moi mon livre vous
avez la gentillesse de le rappeler il
est sur la manière dont les journalistes
ont couvert toute cette période c'était
aussi le thème de ce documentaire
partiellement après votre livre
partiellement le documentaire peut
donner l'impression que les journalistes
ont formidablement ouvert le nazisme
qu'ils étaient sur le coup qu'ils ont
raconté ce qui se passait en mettant en
valeur essentiellement deux journalistes
c'est ce que dont il est question
essentiellement dans le documentaire et
bien morair qui est le correspondant du
d'un journal de Chicago et Dorothy
Thompson qui est une journaliste
américaine qui a eu la particularité et
de rôti Joseph bien entendu qui a eu la
particularité de rencontrer Hitler et de
faire un petit quickbook pas clair ce
qui lui a valu tout de suite d'être en
disgrâce par rapport au nazis or ces
deux journalistes il faut quand même le
dire constitue l'exception c'est à dire
l'exception de ceux qui ont vu qui ont
raconté et qui ont fait leur boulot la
plupart des journalistes des 200
journalistes occidentaux qui sont en
poste à Berlin quand Hitler arrive au
pouvoir en 33 sont des gens qui sont qui
sont là avant ils étaient là sur Weimar
ils vont rester pendant une partie de la
période nazie mais eux ne travaillent
pas du tout de la même manière
c'est-à-dire que eux vont beaucoup moins
raconter ce qu'il voit pourtant à Berlin
c'est à dire les premiers incidents
antisémites les premiers bastonnages les
premiers tabassages les les premières
discriminations ils vont beaucoup moins
raconter que les autres pour une série
de raisons sur lesquelles on pourra
revenir parce que c'est intéressant
notamment celle que je donne dans le
documentaire c'est à dire que leur
rédacteur en chef leur propriétaire sont
viscéralement anti-communiste et donc ne
les poussent pas de l'épouse pas à
critiquer Hitler et puis aussi plein de
raisons notamment le fait qu'ils sont
sur place
qui sont pour la plupart tous d'ailleurs
germanophones c'est d'ailleurs une
partie de leur plus value
professionnelle et que ils ont envie de
rester ils ont une restée vous le dites
dans votre livre c'est d'être exclure en
fait
d'être exclus oui ils ont pas envie
d'être virés par les nazis alors qui ne
les nazis renvoient morèrent le gars du
ce sera même le premier journaliste
étrangère être envoyé parce que lui il a
vraiment voilà il y en a vraiment trop
fait mais sinon les nazis ne renvoient
pas ils ont ils ont des manières
beaucoup plus sournoises c'est à dire
que quand les correspondants partent en
vacances l'été ils n'ont pas de visa de
Retour pour revenir à la rentrée donc
finalement ça ça revient ça revient ça
revient à ce qu'il soit renvoyé du pays
mais voilà nos deux héros nos trois
héros sont l'exception sans l'exception
et on comprendrait pas bien les la
question des opinions occidentales et
sans doute des classes politiques que
aussi européenne et occidentales de 33 à
39 si on n'avait pas en tête que la
plupart des journaux français vont
gommer
les premiers les premières
discriminations les les
atteintes à la liberté des nazis et le
une partie de la presse pas toutes mais
une partie de la presse pas la presse
communiste notamment pour pour
réhabiliter un peu
les comics français en tout cas sur ce
point sur ce point très précis mais une
partie de la presse va être extrêmement
complaisante par rapport au nazis vous
dites dans votre livre je parle bien
évidemment sous votre contrôle
l'antisémitisme sous la République de
Weimar même si les manuels scolaires ne
l'évoque pas c'est une donnée
essentielle
elle explique elle aussi l'indifférence
des médias étrangers du point de vue de
l'antisémitisme le 30 janvier 33 ne
marque pas une rupture radicale disons
plutôt exactement qu'il s'inscrit autant
dans la continuité qui l'opèrent une
rupture alors là je parle pas là de
l'antisémitisme d'État il n'y a pas
d'antisémitisme d'État sous Viber quand
on parle d'antisémitisme c'est déjà
l'antisémitisme des nazis qui depuis en
gros 29 avec la formation DSA
occupe les rues
occupent le terrain dans les villes
moyennes et ce voilà ce signal déjà par
une pression sur les communautés juives
alors d'accord avec ça
oui en partie d'accord ce que je voulais
dire quand même c'est que on dit ce que
vous avez dit ce qui n'est pas faux bien
sûr que les nazis sont arrivés
légalement au pouvoir mais il faut voir
aussi ce qui était la rue allemande dans
les années qui ont précédé
ils ont le 30 janvier 33 pour prendre
une date c'était une rue qui était d'une
extraordinaire violence
ou les différents partis nazis
communistes socialiste avec des sortes
de milice armés 2010 et où on tuait avec
une relative facilité donc c'est un déjà
un climat d'extrême violence qui qui est
aussi une des explications de l'arrivée
de Hitler et cette conscience de
l'ancien mythisme on la voit par exemple
chez Kessel très vite que celle écrit
aussi d'en gringuard comme d'ailleurs
Romain Gary sous son nom de kacef il
publie en feuilleton en 35 me
semble-t-il la passion du sans souci qui
est le premier roman qui paraîtra après
en roman qui est le premier roman qui
évoque les camps de concentration
allemand et où vous avez un couple de
socialistes je pense allemand mais aussi
le petit enfant juif d'avis donc il y a
chez certains une conscience de cette
antisémitisme maintenant l'antimitisme
dans les années 20
c'est une chose qui est relativement
partagée partout pas seulement en
Allemagne ou pas seulement en Allemagne
on sort quand même de la Première Guerre
mondiale les nations qui ont émergé je
pense par exemple la Pologne ont émergé
avec des des vagues d'anxiété avec des
pogromes on sort de la grande vague de
qui a fait des plus en dizaines de
milliers de morts ce qu'on a changé
d'échelle par rapport au programme
traditionnel de l'empire de sariste qui
a accompagné la fin de la guerre en
Ukraine et qui a d'ailleurs vu en France
la naissance de la ligue contre les
pogromes c'est-à-dire de la Lyca donc on
peut dire qu'il y a une
et quelque chose d'assez répandu et
qu'il n'est pas non plus stigmatisé
comme il l'est aujourd'hui après la
Shoah et en France et en France et en
France alors il y a pas de Rome en
France dans les années 20 et 30 mais il
y a un antisémitisme intellectuel avec
l'Action française et politique qui est
absolument c'est ça qui est difficile à
comprendre c'est qu'aujourd'hui
des fois de façon un peu naïve on a
tendance à mettre tout sous le label
extrême droite il faut bien voir que en
France dans les années 20 dans les
années 30 on pouvait être antisémite et
germanophobe et les deux souvent se
confondaient en fait c'est à dire que
vous aviez à la droite de l'échiquier
politique français à la droite du monde
intellectuel à la droite du ou à
l'extrême droite du Parlement des gens
qui étaient totalement hostiles à
l'Allemagne qu'elles soient République
de Weimar ou hitlérienne était à la
limite un détail et puis cette droite
était également antisémite et ce qui
choquait éventuellement cette droite pas
l'antisémitisme des nazis c'était
éventuellement les intentions de Hitler
de remettre en cause les traités les
intentions de Hitler par rapport à la
France et Hitler lui-même en était
conscient puisqu'il a essayé de faire en
sorte que le livre dans lequel beaucoup
de choses sont écrites qu'il suffisait
de lire Minecraft et bien paraît en
français dans des versions un petit peu
édulcorées concernant les Français pas
concernant l'antisémitisme il y avait
des antisémites en France bon mais le
sentiment très anti français qui
prédomine dans le mannekampf allemand au
fond ce sont parfois des nationalistes
français qui ont fait lire mannequin pas
pour dire c'est bien pour dire attention
il y a un danger là mais par
germanophobie pas du tout par philo
c'est mythisme vraiment pas et avant que
je redonne la parole à Daniel sutermann
décrivez-nous l'ambiance la tonalité des
échanges parlementaires dans cette
montée en puissance du nazisme cet
avènement de du parti nazi comme
première formation politique allemande
est-ce que c'est une préoccupation
majeure qu'elle fait débat débat
passionnés au sein de la Chambre des
députés à l'époque ou pas pas tellement
pas tellement alors il y a des des
chambres en France on a un rythme
beaucoup plus régulier avec des
élections législatives tous les quatre
ans 1924 38 32 36 la présidentielle et
c'est n'existe pas vraiment le président
de la République a très peu de pouvoir
il est élu par les parlementaires donc
on a un rythme électoral différent on a
des alternances mais au fond ce qui
préoccupe les hommes politiques français
c'est le péril rouge c'est Moscou ce
sont les soviets et plus tard
éventuellement Staline mais ce qui se
passe en Allemagne et largement
sous-estimé alors j'ai vu la curiosité
de regarder un petit peu les archives
les services de renseignement puisque
les services de renseignement français
et les autorités politiques et on voit
bien que les moyens importants sont mis
sur l'URSS et assez peu sur l'Allemagne
on met beaucoup de temps à mesurer qu'il
y a un danger que l'Allemagne réarme
pour de bons quant à Hitler il est très
longtemps sous-estimé les Français l'ont
identifié assez tôt il y avait une
commission interaliée des territoires
drainants qui a fait une fiche sur
Hitler dès le milieu des années 20 mais
cette fiche est bourrée d'erreurs et en
particulier une énorme erreur
d'appréciation on décrit finalement une
sorte de un agitateur qui à la tête
d'une sorte de service d'ordre qui va
obéir aux grands industriels allemands
et là c'est très très naïf c'est pas du
tout ce qui va se passer vraiment
sous-estime le danger allemand et à
droite on a quelques hommes politiques
qui font un petit peu attention on a un
journaliste qui va devenir homme
politique c'est Henri de kerylis qui est
quelqu'un tout à fait intéressant qui
est un républicain national qui est pour
un pour voir fort en France mais dans le
cadre de la République et qui lui tout
en étant anti-communiste et favorable à
une alliance avec l'URSS contre
l'Allemagne nazie mais lui aussi est une
pure exception d'ailleurs vous le
soulignez dans votre livre à cette peur
du rouge cette peur du bolchevisme
expliquerait en partie l'aveuglement
dont on fait preuve une grande partie
dites-vous dans votre livre des
correspondants étrangers présent à
Berlin et ce qui est intéressant je vous
écoute et ce qui est intéressant c'est
de réfléchir sur l'interaction qui peut
y avoir entre le fait que les services
de renseignement finalement sont plus
branchés sur les les soviettes que sur
les nazis et ce que je racontais tout à
l'heure sur la presse parce que tout ça
est lié si vous voulez les politiques
français lisent la presse évidemment ils
ont les notes des ambassades etc et en
l'occurrence d'ailleurs le l'ambassadeur
français à Berlin André François Poncet
tout en étant très bien dans le cours
auprès des nazis dit les choses il dit
les choses dans ces notes donc les les
cachent pas donc les politiques
françaises sont informés par leur
ambassadeur mais ils ont pas informés
par la presse et les les espions
français le système français espionnage
j'imagine qu'ils disent aussi les
journaux enfin je veux dire tout ça
ils utilisent aussi la couverture de
journalistes pour envoyer des
observateurs il y a une histoire à je
veux pas détailler parce que ce serait
beaucoup trop long mais qui est
passionnante c'est celle de Xavier de
haute cloque donc cousin germain du
futur maréchal Leclerc qui va comme
reporter en Allemagne alors qu'il lui
voit des choses comprend des choses
écrit des choses il meurt empoisonné en
1935 c'est-à-dire que les nazis avaient
aussi des moyens de rétorsion il y avait
des journaux des journalistes qui
étaient achetés et puis il y avait des
journalistes
mais il meurt à 38 ans dans des
conditions extrêmement troubles suite à
une série de reportages c'est des choses
qui arrivent mais c'est tout autre
élément selon vous qui qui ont pu
concourir à l'aveuglement c'est le terme
que vous utilisez dans votre livre des
confrères qui étaient présents à
l'époque en Allemagne
il y en a plein d'autres et y compris il
y en a certains qui ont y compris des
bonnes raisons professionnelles alors on
a dit qu'ils sont pas envie de se faire
virer
ils ont ils sont Hitler fait vendre
dites-vous
aujourd'hui la
qui veut vendre et donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle voilà les médias
occidentaux un pas seulement les
Français mais Britanniques les
Américains ont envie de maintenir leur
bureau à Berlin les photos en provenance
d'Allemagne se vendent bien les papiers
sont lus et puis après les
correspondants si vous voulez ils sont
comme ça ça explique la complaisance
donc vous parlez une forme de
complaisance comme ça c'est une des
explications après ils sont comme tous
les correspondants étrangers dans un
pays étranger ils ont besoin de source
ça veut dire qu'ils ont besoin de
rencontrer le personnel dirigeant et ils
ont besoin d'avoir des accès donc il y a
tout un système les nazis ont mis sur
pied un système de de avec les avec
l'Association de la presse étrangère ils
ont mis sur pied un système de
rencontres régulières autour d'une bière
et d'un sandwich à l'allemande donc tous
les les ministres nazis et le bells les
urines deviennent régulièrement
rencontrer les correspondants
occidentaux ça papote autour d'une bière
et évidemment si on est viré de ça on a
plus de on plus ta formation car le
Graal du Graal c'est d'avoir une
interview d'Hitler et ça c'est Fernand
Brinon peu de temps après la prise de
pouvoir de Hitler qui va faire la une du
matin avec une interview du chancelier
bon on saura après Fernand Bruno il est
totalement acheté par l'Allemagne il va
présider le comité France - Allemagne
etc mais dans l'interview qui paraît se
faire erreur en novembre 33 elle est
extrêmement rassurante pour les Français
Hitler célèbre la douleur des
combattants aussi bien français que
allemand les anciens combattants de la
Première Guerre mondiale il tient des
propos plutôt rassurants donc le lecteur
du matin qui voit cette interview
exclusive du chancelier Hitler parce
qu'on dit le chancelier Hitler on le
respecte bien se dit bon bah finalement
voilà il va mater des communistes il va
remettre un peu d'ordre dans son pays il
va pas nous embêter et donc
effectivement on peut parler
d'aveuglement mais parce que les nazis
sont aussi des princes de la propagande
Anna du York Bruno funini nous a dit
tout à l'heure oui mannequin bien sûr il
s'est dit dans le film aussi mannequin
tout y était tout alors pas les fours
crématoires d'abord mais qui était et
alors ça est-ce que les on avait lu ce
que les décisionnaires les journalistes
ceux qui devaient rendre compte avaient
lu mannequin fallait analysé Minecraft
alors d'abord il y a une édition de
meinkamp qui a été publiant en France
par la Ligue 1 c'est-à-dire une une
édition de mise en garde il faut lire
main parce que il y a mais alors le taux
dans Minecraft non non vous avez
parfaitement raison c'est anti-français
c'est anti-communiste c'est
anticapitaliste
c'est aussi antisémite mais moi ce qui
me frappe en vous en vous écoutant c'est
cette espèce de
de position de surplomb qu'on a nous
aujourd'hui c'est nous on sait
décrochera la Seconde Guerre mondiale on
sait qu'il y a eu la Shoah donc on a
déjà un prix dans lequel on juge
finalement les correspondants de presse
à la lumière de ce qu'on sait nous
aujourd'hui
et
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire le bureau
mais est-ce qu'on voit tout et est-ce
qu'on voit des choses qui n'ont pas
encore
pris forme
si on fait un plan à l'échelle 1 1 on
verra ce qu'on voit dans la rue quand on
s'élève on voit mieux les lignes de
force et quand on est très haut on voit
les lignes de force nous aujourd'hui on
voit les lignes de force pourquoi
quelqu'un comme Joseph Kessel qui était
quand même un de vos confrères de mon
point de vue les plus talentueux fait à
la fois les articles qu'il fait qu'on
entend dans le documentaire à la fois ce
feuilleton d'engrais noir dans Grégoire
le Grégoire qui va être à la pointe de
l'anxémitisme collaborationniste pendant
l'occupation donc on a tout ça mais mêlé
à tellement d'autres choses pourquoi tu
essaies de le faire parce que lui il
vient il vient de Paris donc il a pas
peur de se faire virer comme les gens
qui sont sur place et qui eux veulent et
qui eux veulent rester à Berlin mais il
y en a qui voit et qui raconte pas il y
a un Américain qui se fait lui-même
tabasser par un défilé sa dans une rue
parce qu'il a pas fait le il a pas fait
le salut au passage de l'accord de DSA
il se fait tabasser il ne le racontera
pas il y a un autre alors ce qu'il y a
aussi ce qu'il faut bien il y a aussi la
proximité on va dire du petit groupe que
forme à Berlin les correspondants
occidentaux les diplomates
occidentaux et le le personnel nazi la
la fille de l'ambassadeur américain sort
avec le premier directeur de la Gestapo
en 33 ils sont ensemble
cette fille
cette fille martadod
est aussi camarade avec des journalistes
américains c'est normal tout ce monde-là
copine
l'été 33 ils vont faire une virée en
Allemagne il fait beau tout va bien il
se retrouve dans un hôtel à Nuremberg et
dans un hôtel à Nuremberg ils assistent
dans le hall de leur hôtel à la au quasi
lynchage
c'est une femme juive par DSA
la fille de l'ambassadeur va demander
aux journalistes de surtout pas raconter
ça parce que ça la mettrait en position
délicate par rapport à son père donc
bien sûr que pour nous aujourd'hui c'est
facile comme vous dites on est très
intelligent mais c'est vrai on est on
est en surplomb en même temps il y a des
réflexes de base que n'ont pas les les
confrères et juste pour en finir et que
Joseph Kessel parce que Joseph Kessel il
est présent en 32 à l'occasion de la
présidentielle dont on a parlé il sera
aussi présent 45 au procès de Nuremberg
est-ce qu'il y a une forme de mea culpa
de la part du grand journaliste qui
était celle alors après coup est-ce
qu'il y a une forme de mea culpable
je ne sais pas mais ce qui est très
intéressant c'est ce que j'ai fait pour
pour mon livre pour Bernard 33 c'est de
comparer leurs articles de l'époque avec
les livres de souvenirs qu'ils ont
publié après la guerre et alors les
livres de souvenirs c'est j'ai bien vu
que j'y étais j'ai raconté que et quand
vous comparez ce qu'ils écrivent après
la guerre parfois de la même scène et ce
qu'ils ont écrit sur le moment c'est
tout à fait fascinant le correspondant
américain de associé de presse dans le
rôle est déterminant les correspondants
des agences jouent un rôle très
importants dans la
dans la distribution de l'information
mondiale à un moment est amené par par
de Belz dans une visite un peu potamine
d'une d'un des premiers camps de
concentration allemand
dans sa dépêche il raconte que tout va
bien que les détenus lui disent que
voilà ils ont des livres les repas sont
bons la soupe est bonne
dans son livre de souvenirs publié après
guerre il va raconter que ce ce camp
était véritablement un enfer et qu'il
l'a bien vu il l'a tu l'as bien vu lors
de sa visite est-ce qu'il spécificité
française dans ces années 30 une rupture
dans le traitement de la du nazisme et
cette fois après 33 de la prise de
pouvoir
de l'autoritarisme dont fait partie ce
régime parce qu'en France on a eu 34 il
faut se souvenir que l'extrême droite
française tout de même a voulu d'ici
prendre l'Assemblée nationale bien
entendu ensuite il y a eu le Front
populaire
il y a eu un assaut contre le Palais
Bourbon qui était le siège de la Chambre
des députés mais pour des raisons qui
sont liées à l'affaire Stavisky et en
fait bon il y a eu là il s'est très
compliqué parce qu'il y a des mouvements
d'anciens combattants et puis il y a des
ligues dont certaines se réclament plus
du fascisme que du nazisme il y a des
royalistes il y a aussi des communistes
de larac donc tout ça tout ça est très
complexe on peut difficilement
difficilement comparé en fait il y a
très peu avant l'occupation il y a très
peu de mouvements français y compris à
l'extrême droite qui se réclame du
nazisme certains peuvent s'en inspirer
dans des dans des cycles dans des tenues
etc mais le sentiment anti-allemand est
tellement fort dans la France d'après
14-18 que ce serait politiquement du
suicide c'est plus tard que des gens
vont se raccrocher à l'Allemagne et
d'ailleurs si on regarde la
collaboration les
ultras de la collaboration vont être
assez marginaux c'est plutôt des hommes
politiques venus de la gauche ou du
centre des gens comme Pierre Laval élu
socialiste en 1914 qui va à grenouiller
un petit peu au centre pendant
l'entre-deux-guerres qui va devenir
l'homme liche des Allemands les
Allemands vont recruter dans un
personnel politique tout à fait
classique et vont finalement se méfier
de ces extrémistes qui ne sont pas leur
qui vont être des royalistes des
catholiques dans la France libre on va
trouver aussi des mortsiens c'est
étonnant mais c'est vrai je serais quand
même dire on l'a eu à le traité
d'ailleurs dans cette même émission
j'aurais quand même dire deux mots du
KPD des communistes en général parce que
la dans les graphiques que vous nous
avez montré au début on voit que les
votes nazis on voit pas non plus comment
on a eu cette
radicalisation aux extrêmes et la montée
du KPD
il y a une ligne qui est celle du comité
de l'intentionnel communiste qui est la
ligne classe contre classe on ne salit
pas avec les sociaux très et c'est
valable pour l'Allemagne c'est valable
pour la France à partir de l'arrivée de
hitlero au pouvoir et de la catastrophe
qu'a constitué le nazisme pour le pour
les communistes les communistes ont été
assassinés mis en camps contrat à l'exil
certains traits talentueux comme
petsenberg
en France
et cela d'ailleurs
ça a été une des conséquences de
l'incendie
que les nazis ont mis sur le dos des des
communistes mais à partir de 34 la ligne
du communautaire ne bouge change et au
lieu d'avoir cette stratégie classe
contre classe donc taper des contre
nazisme CAPD contre SPD contre les on a
le début des stratégies dites frontiste
d'union qui vont donner le Front
populaire et le Front populaire c'est
quand même un mouvement que
j'appellerais anti-nazie le pain la paix
la liberté donc la paix et la liberté
c'est de partie du slogan donc à partir
de ce moment-là il y a quand même une
configuration qui change même si elle ne
change pas
aussi intégralement qu'on aimerait
peut-être
c'est la fin de l'émission à bientôt
Daniel chose j'entends là que c'est
quasiment les communistes qui ont fait
le 6 février 304 j'entends là que tous
les tous les tous les tous les
personnages
caricature mais il y avait en effet
quelques communistes dans la rue le 6
février 34
rue vous me l'accorderez
j'entends aussi que les ministres que
vous n’êtes la gauche enfin ça
plus compliqué
le mot de la fin Daniela juste sur le
l'extrême droite l'Allemagne etc
en 38 le la configuration change
à nouveau rechange quand on Hitler a
envahi l'Autriche et quand il menace la
Tchécoslovaquie et ensuite quand il
quand il envahit la Tchécoslovaquie à
quoi on va assister on va assister au
fait qu'un journal comme je suis partout
par exemple va être un des derniers un
des plus acharnés pacifiste de la presse
française et de et du paysage politique
français je suis partout va tout faire
chaque semaine pour éviter que la France
entre en guerre avec les entre en guerre
avec les nazis ils vont vilipender les
wattes en guerre ils vont vilipender
chaque semaine le malheureux en rides
keryliss qui se effectivement ce député
de droite qui lui avait tout compris
avait tout compris avant tout le monde
même s'il était pas même s'il était pas
en surprenant si vous me permettez le
pacifisme a été une chose très bien
partagée notamment par les instits parce
que on sortait quand même il faut pas
l'oublier on n'y a pas du tout allusion
vous sentez quand même dans de la Grande
Guerre de cette guerre qui a été
terrible de 14-18 et beaucoup de gens ne
voulaient pas recommencer donc il y a
quelque chose dans le Pacifique qui peut
aussi
qui nécessite quand même aussi un
minimum de compréhension même si on
n'est pas d'accord ça sera le mot de la
fin vraiment un grand merci à tous les
trois d'avoir participé à ce débat doc
aujourd'hui vos réactions et à mon avis
elle risque d'être nombreuses à
l'occasion de cette émission hashtag des
Badoc sur Twitter je compte sur vous
pour réagir à ce que seront bien entendu
ces réactions merci à sel massalik comme
à la coutumée à préparer cette émission
je vous donne rendez-vous pour un
prochain débat doc et ça sera bien sûr à
notre leader avec son documentaire et
son débat à très bientôt
[Musique]